[Music]
since we're running about 10 minutes
late I'd like to start the afternoon
session after a exciting morning in
which we laid out the general principles
we're now going to this afternoon move
more into the particulars and the
afternoon session is divided into two
parts the first part of which will begin
now which is basic research and industry
perspectives on the life physical and
information sciences and it's a great
pleasure to introduce as the chairman of
the first of the afternoon sessions I
was gonna say my counterpart at Harvard
that is jeremy knowles except first of
all of course actually i'm gonna
suppress my casted comments about
Harvard secondly he has not just the
sciences but the arts which I understand
are also a component of education at
Harvard although I'm never sure Jeremy
has had a distinguished career his
undergraduate and graduate work and
early part of his professional career
were all at Oxford at Balliol and Wadham
College for the former in the latter he
then whoever made occasional trips to
the United States he was a visiting
faculty member at Harvard put me at Yale
in 69 and 71 and a visiting professor at
Harvard in 73 obviously there was
something on this side of the ocean that
was drawing him here then finally in 74
he made the transition and joined the
Harvard faculty permanently as professor
of chemistry his research is on the
borderline between chemistry and
biochemistry he's in fact made truly
distinguished contributions in bio
biochemistry and specifically on enzyme
catalyzed reactions and on the evolution
of enzyme function in 1971 he
took on the daunting task of being Dean
of the Faculty of Arts and Sciences at
Harvard he like all of our other
speakers today has received an
extraordinarily large number of honors
including being a fellow of the Royal
Society as a Canadian the one I like
best is that he was appointed commander
of the British Empire which I guess
means he's my commander as well my
counterpart in the Queen's birthdays
honors of 1993
Jeremy Knowles this morning Bob
by being excessively gracious to his
Provost tried to raise his salary why
he's being nice to me I can't imagine
except I suppose for the possibility
that he has some college-age children
wishing to go to a really distinguished
institution everything comes to she who
waits I a reasonably stirring morning I
hope we're going to have a very stirring
afternoon what I hope will happen this
afternoon is that we shall be able to
discuss the shifting flow of ideas of
people and information and actually
dollars amongst three the three places
represented here today namely government
industry and academia and this concern
about the flow of people and of
information and knowledge and ideas and
perhaps equally importantly dollars is
something that we must surely all attend
to I'm glad to say that essentially
every one of our six speakers this
afternoon what I might call happy
hybrids in the sense that they
essentially have not mutants hi
that they have I'm causing a great stir
in the front row I'm afraid but having
touched in their lives government
industry and academia and our first
speakers dr. Leon Rosenberg who did
who's the only MD in case any of you
were feeling unwell
on our program receiving the MD in 1957
from the University of Wisconsin he then
went more or less to government that is
to say to the NIH as an investigator in
the National Cancer Institute for six
years Yale seduced him away and he
stayed in that institution in a number
of posts founding the Department of
Human Genetics
and ending there as the Dean of Yale
School of Medicine and as you all know
in 1991 he succumbed again to a
different temptation and became
president of bristol-myers Squibb
pharmaceutical Research Institute the
post he now holds Leon
good afternoon everyone for a former
longtime member of academia like myself
it's always a great pleasure to return
to the campuses of institutions like MIT
even if only for a few hours and even I
might add on an uncommon Lee cold day in
New England whatever the temperature is
here today I have a feeling that if we
correct for the windchill factor of the
Republican response to the President's
budget message it is colder in
Washington than it is in Boston in fact
the the idea that so many of us have
chosen to brave perhaps Boston's coldest
winter day this year is testimony to the
importance of what we're here to talk
about science in the national interest
or put another way the need for a
national rededication to basic research
i used the word rededicate because
events of the past several years raised
serious questions in my mind about our
national dedication to science in
general and to basic science in
particular I am and I remain deeply
concerned that our national research
effort is slowly being undermined slowly
enough in fact to go unnoticed for too
long
slowly enough that only now are the
threats becoming apparent threats to our
great university centers of basic
research and threats to the future
competitiveness economic vitality and
scientific preeminence of the
pharmaceutical and other American
industries which depend and have
depended for so long on fundamental
discoveries made here and at the other
research intensive universities that
together should constitute for all of us
a national treasure because we are
meeting today at an institution renowned
for its mathematical prowess
it is perhaps appropriate that I offer
some numbers
to begin my remarks specifically numbers
which I believe indicate the unstable
and uncertain status of basic research
in this country and I suspect these
numbers are well-known to most all of
you
in 1993 the last year for which we have
reliable data total US support of
non-defense research and development was
about 1.9 percent of the GDP an amount
well below those in both Germany and
Japan even more sobering the amount of
federal funding which supports basic
research the engine that drives our
nation's industrial enterprise totaled
only 0.2 percent of GDP these figures
alone should be a clarion call for
anyone truly concerned about sustaining
a strong basic research effort if we
believe basic research to be the venture
capital of America we must ensure that
funding levels are meaningful this
investment in the future must increase
if we are serious about maintaining the
nation's economic prosperity and most
importantly this investment must
increase if the American people are to
continue having the benefits of improved
health and quality of life that our past
investment in basic research has
provided the people of this country
indeed of all countries improving health
and the quality of life the
pharmaceutical industry has accomplished
much toward the universal hope of all
people to live longer and healthier
lives the American pharmaceutical
industry is the world's unquestioned
leader in the discovery and development
of life-saving medicines and over the
last 50 years has generated a flow of
new drug treatments which have prolonged
life reduced suffering and dramatically
improved the standard of Health for the
world's people antibiotics antivirals
antidepressants antihypertensives yet
everyone here knows that the
pharmaceutical industry
alone is not responsible for these
accomplishments rather it has stood on
the shoulders of this country's
world-class basic scientists and
academia the US medical research
Enterprise is comprised of a unique
collaboration of government academia
industry not-for-profit Institute's
foundations and voluntary health
agencies no one major participant leads
the enterprise rather it is
characterized increasingly by
partnership and interdependence
throughout the 50 years in which the
national effort has developed government
and academia z' relationships have taken
many forms unrestricted grants research
contracts strategic alliances the vast
bulk of federal research funds
appropriated to nih and NSF have been
granted to academic investigators who
have in turn produced both a steady
stream of exciting new information and
the next generation of medical
scientists over 50% of PhD students in
the life sciences in our country are
supported by NIH research grants these
doctorate level scientists in turn have
trained a generation of research
technicians and assistants the
pharmaceutical industry where I now work
has benefited enormously from the
discoveries these basic researchers have
made and from their laboratory serving
as training grounds for young scientists
ideas and people flow increasingly
bi-directionally between universities
and corporations and the supply of
qualified scientists who gained their
training within the academic research
community remains absolutely critical to
America maintaining its scientific and
industrial preeminence in the future
today the pharmaceutical industry
involves itself with academia in much
the same way that government does
through grants contracts and alliances
more
recently interactions between government
and industry have increased through
cooperative research and development
agreements known as craters and other
technology transfer instruments thus
each of the major three participants in
the medical research Enterprise has a
remarkably large stake in what happens
to the others the pharmaceutical
industry has benefited from the
discoveries and academic laboratories
which have transformed our understanding
of living organisms industry for its
part has used this information to
explore disease mechanisms and translate
these discoveries into new strategies to
diagnose treat and even cure disease tax
all one of my company's newest
anti-cancer products illustrates I
believe the distinct role played by each
partner within the medical enterprise
and the interaction so critical to their
individual and collective success tax
all as some of you may know was finally
introduced to the marketplace in 1992
for the treatment of refractory ovarian
cancer and was hailed quickly as the
most important anti-cancer drug in 20
years bristol-myers Squibb spent
hundreds of millions of dollars
developing taxall most importantly
learning how to formulate administer and
manufacture the taxall molecule no small
feat I assure you you may recall that
the active ingredient in taxall is
derived from the bark of the yew tree
and concerns over depleting yew trees in
the Pacific region for tax all supplies
initially caused a great deal of concern
and controversy controversy that was put
to rest by the company's ability to
extract tax all from twigs and needles
rather than from tree bark but what is
important for this discussion is to
remind ourselves that the work that led
to our company developing tax all began
20 years earlier at the Einsteins
School of Medicine in the early 70s
through grants from NIH subsequently tax
all's preliminary evidence of being
clinically efficacious was demonstrated
by NCI sponsored trials in academic
centers further bristol-myers Squibb
finally obtained access to tax all
through a government sponsored crater
tax all today is approved to treat
ovarian and breast cancer and many other
studies are underway to define its value
and cancers of the lung head and neck
stomach and pancreas we still don't know
nor will we know for a number of years
the full extent of tax all's benefits
but thousands of cancer patients around
the world have been treated successfully
because government academia and industry
have worked in partnership to see that
tax all's promise was fulfilled tax
all's development followed a long
uncertain arduous path from basic
science laboratory to the bedside the
NCI sent botanists to gather plant
specimens that might have medicinal uses
and chemistry work revealed how this
taxane prevented cells from dividing
that work led the way to studies that
demonstrated tax all's potential and
ultimately to its success in clinical
trials our national commitment to basic
research must continue to cherish such
unfettered research that often yields
exceptional yet unexpected advancements
like the story of tax awe and I have
another brief story to tell you it is
about hydroxyurea a drug recently in the
headlines which epitomizes the
unpredictable value of basic research
hydroxyurea was first marketed by my
company in 1968 for the treatment of
leukemia skin cancer and other types of
malignancies we knew that it bound to
DNA and
although considered a significant new
treatment it has surely never been a
major commercial success nothing to be
called a blockbuster or anything like it
today 25 years later this compound with
no longer proprietary rights was shown
and studies funded by the National Heart
Lung and Blood Institute just two weeks
ago to be the first important
breakthrough in treating sickle cell
anemia a common inherited and often
debilitating blood disorder afflicting
people of African descent the story of
hydrea and sickle cell anemia is to me a
wonderful example of what Peter
Eisenberger of Princeton University
calls quote the unanticipated
developments of unrestricted research
which create new opportunities that
could not be previously identified
unquote recently the Battelle Memorial
Institute announced the results of its
annual survey on US scientific research
and new product development the survey
reports that industry R&D spending will
continue moving toward product
development and away from basic research
and that even the most basic research
conducted in industry will have an
application towards satisfying specific
corporate product and process needs as
companies attempt to make R&D spending
pay off more quickly I have learned in
the past two years how rapidly companies
make changes in their R&D budgets when
the bottom line demands that they do so
something that I recommend as a as an
informative exercise for all of you who
do science
if if this trend continues this trend of
of R&D spending an industry needing to
have a return on investment and I
believe it will the need for more basic
research sponsored by publicly supported
government funds and conducted by
academic investigators devoid of any
dedicated national objective other than
new knowledge will become increasingly
imperative such fundamental work must
continue if we are to discover the next
hydroxyurea or the next axle or the next
AZT or the next cephalosporin effective
against resistance staphylococci today's
meeting was called in part to gain input
from the industrial sectors which rely
heavily on the fruits of basic research
as the head of a pharmaceutical
company's Research Institute my job is
to oversee the translation of exciting
new science into safe efficacious and
cost-effective medicines neither my
colleagues holding similar positions and
other companies in our eye can
accomplish this objective without a
national commitment to sustaining basic
research our collective responsibilities
here today all of us are equally
difficult determining how best to foster
and sustain basic research at such
levels that it will thrive and continue
to provide the insights that lead to
important developments in industrial
sectors pharmaceutical and others let me
offer some initial recommendations that
relate specifically to medical research
they come largely from research
America's 1994 consensus statement in
support of medical research first
incorporate the promotion of medical
research as an integral element of any
healthcare reform measure second
increase the capacity of NIH NSF the VA
and the CDC to support medical research
by growing the budget
for these organizations I I applaud
President Clinton's 1996 budget requests
for NIH and NSF and his stated goal of
increasing the national capability for
basic medical research I only wish that
he had boldly demanded more fourth
encouraged the discovery and development
of innovative and effective
pharmaceuticals devices and other agents
by private industry v ensure a stable
revenue stream to academic health
centers for medical research and
education of medical scientists provide
these centers with incentives for
heightened interaction with industry
voluntary health agencies and other
private sector sources of medical
research support events of the past year
suggests to me that no matter how
precarious the stream of funding is it
places like MIT it is far more
precarious at the major academic health
centers of universities like Harvard and
Yale and Columbia and Duke and Stanford
and others as an incurable optimist a
valuable profile I might add for
somebody heading pharmaceutical R&D I'm
I'm encouraged by the recent signals
emanating from Washington and by what
appears to be the framework for
bipartisan support of science between
the administration and Congress but we
must see to it that these encouraging
words translate into deeds setting broad
national goals which has been suggested
by the administration may be one step
toward that end but goals won't be
realized if policies and mechanisms do
not exist which sustain our basic
science engine and promote translation
of fundamental science
to the clinic in the marketplace this
process requires healthy institutions
and practical coherent federal policies
which balance short and long term
research expectations in considering any
actions today we must bear in mind the
impact they will have on the future
medical science truly is on the brink of
discovering new insights into the
fundamental workings of the human genome
and the immune system and the
fundamental mechanisms responsible for
major diseases such as cancer
Alzheimer's aids diabetes and many other
afflictions of the aged the promise of
medical science vastly exceeds its
progress to date a statement that I and
many other of my colleagues have made
many times and I will say it again the
promise of medical science vastly
exceeds its progress to date that is not
a slogan it is not hyperbole it is not a
cliche it is the deeply held belief that
has been educated and tempered by 35
years of direct involvement with a
marvelous thing called the American
medical research enterprise thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much we're going to move
to the other half of life as it were of
our life segment before we have any
discussion of dr. Rosenberg's paper so
let me introduce with great pleasure
Phil sharp we come to a bunch a sequence
in the program of chemists or that is to
say X chemists professor sharp got his
PhD in chemistry and his a B for that
matter his PhD from the University of
Illinois in Urbana he then began a mild
transformation by going to Caltech and
then to Cold Spring Harbor before coming
here in 1974 as a biologist and not
uncommon route for chemists to follow in
fact since 1991 he has been head of
biology at MIT as you all know he
discovered independently in 1977 that
you can hire genes a split and there
began an immense effort on RNA splicing
for which he was awarded the Nobel Prize
two years ago his that's his academic
credential his what about because I
wanted three legs for him he is the
co-founder and has been for many many
years the chairman of the scientific
board of Biogen and not undistinguished
local company and most recently for his
third leg he is now appointed member of
the president's Advisory Council on
science and technology Phil
Thank You Jeremy it's a pleasure to
follow Leon in this program and I was
particularly pleased by his passionate
defense of research and basic research
and what I'll try to do in the next few
moments is just expand on some of the
opportunities in basic research related
to life science and then add a little
detail to those points but before I
begin I want to make a point
about life science and basic research
the issue is the following it's very
difficult to define what is basic
research in life sciences for example is
the discovery of the first aqua gene a
discovery in basic research or a
discovery and Applied Research it
certainly was motivated by a basic
problem trying to understand the
genetics of human cancer and its
discovery will have direct implication
and has had direct impact on the
treatment and diagnosis of human cancer
so in that regard it is applied in a
sense but similarly the discovery of the
first alga gene which is a mutant form
of a natural gene that causes tumor
cells to grow was a fundamental advance
and our understanding of the regulation
of cell growth and division so in a
biological sense it certainly is a basic
discovery and would be defined as basic
research now to my Dean who's a
physicist all of this is applied
research because we're not advancing the
understanding of the physical laws of
nature and to a clinician who's
interested in treatment and care of
patients clearly the isolation of an
oncogene in a laboratory related to cell
growth is basic research because
tomorrow it does not help that clinician
cure the sick or treat the patient thus
when we talk about life sciences and we
discuss this issue of basic and applied
research
I prefer to call it research because it
is terribly difficult to know when one
in this science is moving from one
agenda to another now the case for
supporting research is terribly strong
particularly in life sciences and Leon
has to has commented on that before me
but I'll broaden what Leon's comments
are beyond that of medical science if
you look at the great challenges facing
this country one is providing a good
health for its citizens at a reasonable
cost another is in generation of a
growing economy and the third is
maintaining an attractive and clean
environment and if you think about each
of these three all three are directly
related to issues of life sciences thus
building the science and technology base
in life sciences is critical for the
future of this country in terms of both
public health economy and the
environment now I'll come back to some
opportunities in life science and
applications of basic research but
before I do that or research I want to
comment on just how little we know now
in terms of life sciences we have
seriously studied the fundamental nature
of biological systems for a little more
than 40 years
iDate the beginning at the discovery of
the structure of DNA which was done in
1953 it wasn't until the recombinant DNA
err which is only about 20 years ago
that we were able to isolate and
manipulate genes particularly those
genes from human cells so until this
resolution the revolution the
recombinant DNA err the by chemical
realm of human cells was largely
unexplored today we're in the process of
discovering new genes and new protein
structures almost at a Deeley pace
however we know very little about how
these cellular components interact and
how they execute their chemical
functions this integration step
of integrating our knowledge of the
structure of genes and protein structure
back into how a system works is
something that we're still struggling
with in terms of advances in research
there are many fundamental questions
that one can phrase that illustrates our
lack of knowledge now for example we
don't know how a protein folds into its
native structure even though we've known
for decades now that that structure is
critical for its activity we do not know
how many genes are important for the
formation and maintenance of man do we
have 30,000 genes in our chromosome
50,000 genes hundred thousand genes we
don't know yet finally we know very
little about how the brain works and how
memory is recorded in our brain these
are questions that that lie before us as
well as many others so we can easily get
overwhelmed with the flow of information
and advances in life science research
but we have many things to learn yet the
development of a recombinant DNA
actually brought forward the
biotechnology industry and many novel
therapies and treatments have emerged
from that industry and at this moment
about a hundred thousand people across
the country in some way or another or
employed in this sector it is still a
growing area of technology which is
becoming more diverse with new
discoveries and new societal needs
almost daily in fact the rate of change
of technology and science in the realm
of biotechnology is staggering who would
have suspected a few decades ago that
the nation would be focused on a DNA
fingerprinting evidence in a murder case
are struggling with the issue of an
epidemic of a new virus the AIDS virus
in this society or planning the
sequencing of the total human genome
biotechnology is an activity that
depends on advances in research and is
one that
still rich with discoveries and new
applications now one of the societal
concerns I mentioned before was the
improvement of public health as well as
the containment of cost of providing
that Public Health there are two
opportunities to simultaneously improve
health as well as contained costs the
first of these are prevention in most
cases preventing a disease is clearly
cheaper than curing a disease however
many diseases and at this stage the
largest number of them cannot probably
be cured they're probably related to
natural processes that are inherent to
us as biological organisms the second
opportunity is the development of more
effective treatments and this depends
critically on advances in research
better treatments primarily arise from
the development of better drugs that
reduce damage due to disease or drugs
that cure disease more importantly
better treatments and diagnostic methods
is the only hope of improving the
quality of health care in the future as
well as maintaining the cost of
healthcare the quality of health in an
environment of constrained cost then
depends critically upon research and
innovation for example the most
successful biotechnology product
produced today is Epogen a drug
developed by engine which stimulates the
production of red blood cells this
protein and similar blood factors are
now making it possible to do bone-marrow
transplants on an outpatient basis
without having patients hospitalized
from weeks to months in terms of a
regeneration of their bone marrow system
this will allow more effective and
intense treatment of cancer patients
which will be more effective in curing
them as well as reducing the total cost
of such clinical protocols by reducing
hospitalization costs now at the moment
that's terribly expense
but ten years from now and 20 years from
now it'll be routine and it'll be
something that's within the realm of all
medical centers the process of
developing new pharmaceutical agents is
beginning to rapidly change and I think
Leon referred to this at one time large
pharmaceutical companies almost
exclusively developed new drugs by
screening natural products and I would
comment that taxall is an example of
this this worked reasonably well but it
did not provide a learning curve to make
the development of future drugs easier
the error malla modern excuse me
biological sciences is beginning to
change this tradition in terms of drug
discovery the inner workings of a human
cell the nature of mutations that cause
disease the ability to design animal
models that emulate specific human
diseases is revolutionarily changing how
the pharmaceutical companies and
discoveries work we are only at the
beginning of this revolution these
advances in cell biology are
complementary to advances both in
chemistry in terms of combinatorial
libraries that allow the sampling of
large numbers billions of different
chemical structures and in structural
biology where one can determine the
atomic structure of very complicated
macromolecules with ease and with some
rapidity all of these mech technologies
will merge in the production of a new
pharmaceutical industry producing new
drugs with better treatment and better
quality healthcare there is no area of
life science that offers more
opportunity for research to advance
Public Health than that of neuroscience
in my opinion it is commonly agreed
about that about half of all healthcare
costs are related to mental disease in
some form with a large aging population
these costs will only increase dementia
such as Alzheimer's disease
not yet understood and therefore there
is no effective treatment to either
delay the onset or effectively treat the
symptoms this can be said for almost all
medical health problems the science of
the brain and the processes can now be
approached with a vast new array of
technologies
these include powerful methods to
identify human genetic diseases and the
genes that are responsible for them
related to mental diseases it includes
the ability to manipulate mice as a
model system to understand the workings
of the brain and it also includes
advances in our understanding of the
cell biology of neuronal cells which the
brain is composed of and all of these
come together now to offer rich
opportunities in the area of
neuroscience for advances that will
impact on public health in my comments I
have tried to stress the riches of
opportunities that lie before us in
research in life sciences this research
is in a natural in national interest as
it directly provides a basis for
improving the quality of health care and
for future uses of biological systems to
produce materials and agricultural
products and other useful applications
in addition to these opportunities and
new products the environment impacted by
our technology as I mentioned before is
largely a biological driven issue
thus biological scientists have a lot to
offer and the relationship between
industry in MIT or industry in the basic
science community is one that has
enriched the transfer and development of
the science that I have discussed into
more practical and more worldly uses
thank you
[Applause]
if Rosenberg could come and sit down our
two life scientists are available for
your questions or comments
yes
[Music]
in this I think MIT has been innovative
and the reason that I say that is the
following MIT about five years ago and
in affected about two years ago made the
decision that all students who obtain a
degree at an undergraduate level at this
institution must take a course in
biological science and the impact of
that primarily is going to be in
broadening the technology and science
base of those students who go into civil
engineering and mechanical engineering
and even into physics and economics in
terms of how biological systems work and
what we know and don't know about them
and what we're seeing across the campus
now is something I call the greening of
MIT and that we're seeing increased
interest and relationships between
biological sciences and engineering both
in chemical and mechanical and in civil
and in other areas of technology so I
think at an undergraduate level a
breadth of education particularly in
terms of science and technology provides
a student for the opportunity then to or
the background to move into
environmental and more interdisciplinary
act activities
Frank Rhodes raised this question of
scientific literacy this morning do you
want to say anything from your Yale days
Leon about this problem well I was going
to just pick up on Marcy's question in
that regard because I I think I would
say Marcy that that if we are going to
find exciting people examining questions
about environmental science they are
going to have to understand that
environmental science is after all
science and therefore it comes back to
the issue of whether our people do in
fact have an appreciation of the
principles of science and I think that's
an enormous challenge for everyone who
who cares about science in this country
we have not done a very good job of
extending a scientific literacy to the
population all you have to do is is be a
person who like I do from time to time
go around and try to talk about the
importance of medical research to lay
audiences and you will find out just
exactly how how few people understand
even the words that you use I think it
has been estimated that only 5% of
people in the United States know what
the what the initials NIH stand for in
my company they stand for not invented
here somewhere else they ought to stand
for the National Institutes of Health
and I I think it is it is amazing how
far we have to go in in education in the
elementary schools I used to say to to
doctors that that I used to lecture to
about genetics that my that my 13 year
old son at that time
more genetics than I was sure all of the
members of my audience did and that was
not a put-down of the practicing
physicians that was simply a statement
of what Phil said earlier that the world
of genetics began after most of the
people who were practicing medicine up
until very recently had completed their
education
that's something dramatic that we all
have to understand the evolution of of
the life sciences and the rapidity when
I was a first year medical student a DNA
was dismissed in my biochemistry lecture
in 1953 just months before Watson and
Crick's paper as a macromolecule of
undefined structure and function we must
we must be careful not with these
questions to take from the next session
on Richard after all is education and
suddenly becoming sensitive more
questions it sounded like like one that
might have been directed either to
somebody from Biogen or somebody from
bristol-myers Squibb but I I take the I
take the question to mean what what what
is this biomedical Enterprise as it
relates to proprietary rights as it
relates to cost of research I can only
say this much the the quest for for new
treatments or new diagnostic agents
simply demands in an industry a
possibility of obtaining a return on
I carry around with me some of these
awful numbers like the average cost of
developing a market at pharmaceutical is
250 million dollars that for every for
every compound that comes to market
there are 5000 chemicals that begin
study in a discovery laboratory in
academia or industry that even those
compounds that come in to development in
a company like ours
one in seven that find their way into
animal studies make it to the
marketplace even those that make it into
clinical study one in five in early
clinical studies make it all the way
through and even in the latest clinical
phases that is those in which you are
doing randomized double-blind studies so
called phase three only fifty percent of
those things that make it to Phase three
make it to the marketplace this is a
high-stakes gamble there has to be a
return on those things that make it and
and because if there isn't then then
companies simply will not put the the
billion dollar investments which
characterize a company like mine or
Merck or Pfizer or are a lot of the
large pharmaceutical companies or the
Amgen's and Chiron's and bio gens of the
world because there simply will not be
any way to justify to shareholders the
amount of money that you put in that's
following one of the things that I have
learned in my years of interacting with
bristol-myers Squibb or Biogen or other
companies is that this type of drug
development cannot be done in the
academic sector it's just a scale of
focus and commitment that you cannot
mount in a public sector it has to be
private-sector activity so if the
country wants new drugs to
improve the quality of life than in some
mechanism they're gonna have to fund it
and at this stage and I agree it's the
best way is funded through proprietary
patents and proprietary positions which
then allow the development of new drugs
and it's almost a method of generating
resources for further investment in
society for further development and it
has historically over the last 50 years
given us a vastly improved quality of
health and one that I think we all
appreciate if the question was more
deeply uneasy about intellectual
property which I thought it might be I'm
sure that should go on interestingly in
the break other questions
there was no unease well thank you both
very much we are being reasonably
obedient and good about time so that
there will be a break and there will be
time I trust to discuss some of these
more interesting still interesting items
let me move on now from the life
sciences to the physical sciences and
our first speaker in the physical
sciences is a PhD chemist from Brown
John Locke tag got his his PhD in 1965
and first on a slight detail on an
interesting first job not a detour at
all of course went to the North American
Rockwell Science Center in Los Angeles
in 1970 he K he joined the chemistry
faculty of UCLA but by 1983 he become
deputy director of the Office of Science
and Technology Policy of course in
Washington he was acting science advisor
to President Reagan in the mid 80s and a
member of President Bush's Advisory
Council on science and technology now we
come to his third unambiguous
Legg because in 1990 and since 1990 he
has been the vice president for
technical affairs for the Ford Motor
Company a splendidly eclectic set of
activities in his career dr. Mattei
thank you I got a letter a little while
ago from Chuck vest with an assignment
for today and the assignment was to
discuss quote the evolving nature of
physical science in industry and
concomitant changes in industry
University relationships he didn't ask
for this in 25 words or less
he asked for it in 20 minutes or less
however that gives you two options one
of them is to have a extremely shallow
overview or talk very fast maybe three
options then or as the mathematician
responded when he was asked to describe
a cow consider a one-dimensional cow
that's the tack I'm going to take I'm
going to give a simplified version of a
limited set of aspects in a subset of
industries in other words I choose a
lower dimensional cow it's pretty clear
from what we've heard already that
science-based industries have a very
long history we heard earlier from Joe
Miller about the fact that the dew pot
is almost 200 years old and certainly
for at least three-quarters of that time
the chemical industry has had a very
strong science base going back to the
days of synthetic dyes and then in this
century the science base that has
strongly driven the development of
polymers and very close relationship
with the universities over that whole
time as Jeremy mentioned to you I was a
graduate student slightly south of here
at Brown University in the early 60s and
I can remember once wandering through
the stacks of the library there and
discovering a catalogue from the early
1920s in which the name of the chemistry
department in fact was the department of
wool chemistry so early on well before
the days of government funding there was
a very close relationship between the
academic establishment and the chemical
industries both in the United States and
in Europe we've seen developments of
science-based industries in other fields
too
an obvious example was the evolution
from let me call it truly edisonian days
in the electrical industry to the more
science-based days of the early days of
the research labs at General Electric
with Langmuir among others and of
Westinghouse to today's micro
electronics industry which is extremely
strongly science-based and has had a
very close ties to - particularly
materials developments that have
occurred in in universities now I want
to get to what I really want to talk
about which is my own industry which in
contrast perhaps to the biotechnology
life sciences industries is in most
people's minds most act accurately
described as a Neanderthal industry or
if you want to be charitable a Rust Belt
industry
off the top of your head you wouldn't
tend to think of an industry like this
as having much science base and over
much of its history that's probably true
the automotive industry for practical
purposes is about half the age of DuPont
it started off around the turn of the
century really with a bunch of tinkerers
truly edisonian tinker's mostly people
with no or little formal education but
with a great enthusiasm to experiment
and to make vehicles and literally in
their garages the big transformation of
the industry occurred in the early part
of the century with the introduction of
mass manufacturing and indeed ever since
then the great strength of the
automotive industry and transforming
life around the globe has been the
genius of being able to make extremely
complex consumer products extremely
rapidly and at extremely low cost but
there was very little true technical
innovation that occurred in this
industry between roughly 1915 or so
after carburetors had been invented and
actually the first even the first
aluminum engine was built before that
until the period following World War two
even after World War two the industry
was sort of in in a drift I would say so
then for almost 50 years essentially
nothing happened in this industry during
that time period the involvement of
scientists or indeed a formally educated
engineers in the industry was minimal
up until World War the period after
World War 2 there were essentially no
formally educated
Engineers in the automotive industry
engineers product engineers rose from
being draftsman and manufacturing
engineers burst basically served
apprenticeships on the floor and just
took over larger and larger components
of manufacturing right after World War
two though formally trained product
engineers started moving into the
business and about 20 years ago
manufacturing engineers started having
formal education and but it's only been
probably in the last 10 years that more
than 75% of the manufacturing engineers
even had a degree all this occurred
during a period of enormous prosperity
for this industry just going along going
along raking in the money not having to
do anything else it must have been a
very pleasant life I wish I had been
there but then in the late 60s and the
early 70s an absolute revolution
occurred driven by external forces the
first force probably was the environment
was environmental awareness when people
found out the causes of the SMAW of smog
in the Los Angeles basin scientists did
and the general populace understanding
the fragility of the environment
basically going back to Rachel Carson
and then in the early 70s the oil shock
which made people aware of the fact that
their vehicles were actually burning
gasoline and that gasoline was not free
anymore and not necessarily freely
available these two shocks come
completely through the industry off off
off its pedestal and
it had to respond extremely rapidly how
did it respond extremely rapidly well
fortunately what had occurred about ten
years before that was something that
occurred in many industries in the
United States not unconnected with
veneer Bush's report and that was
setting up research laboratories in
those days just about every respectable
or even not respectable industry so long
as it was large set up a quote
fundamental research laboratory just
sort of had it there just like most
large industry support of the Symphony
Orchestra when this fortunately when the
shock of the of the oil problems and of
the environment came about in the
automotive industry there were these
people who understood science and all of
a sudden they became relevant to their
corporations understanding combustion
and controlling it understand emissions
being able to make engines that had very
high fuel economy became extremely
important basis behind these where
science is related to catalysis for
example surface science a lot of work
necessary on lightweight materials to
make vehicles more efficient the
necessity for computer controls for the
first time in order both to control
emissions and fuel economy the need to
have science-based sensors to to be able
to measure on the fly the amount of
oxygen going into cylinders the amount
coming out carbon dioxide the ability
then as as safety became important to be
able to sense for torque for example for
traction control accelerometers to
control airbags etc so various aspects
of science started becoming important to
this industry but not in the same way as
it did let's
to the chemical industry because the
chemical industry had or developed along
with it a an academic discipline there
is no real academic discipline of the
automobile because it involved like the
airplane it involves basically the
integration of in into a system of a
large number of sciences and
technologies yet it is becoming more and
more of science-based industry two
things have happened as a result of that
one of them is is that we realize that
we can't do it all over the past several
decades as both the demands the
environmental the fuel economy and the
competitive demands have have increased
we have very substantially increased our
R&D it's growing at roughly twice the
rate of industrial R&D in the United
States but even with that growth I mean
for example at Ford now the the R&D
budget - last year was a bit over five
billion dollars which is a substantial
amount of money it's roughly $1 in every
16 that's spent by industry on research
and just one corporation we obviously
can't do it all since we are basically
systems integrators of just about it any
kind of technology that you can think of
be it electronics or materials or
chemical so there been a lot of
experiments going on over the past
decades trying to figure out how we can
work best with suppliers how we can work
best with universities how we can work
best with National Laboratories and even
how we can work best with our with arts
toughest competitors as a result of that
the the three us-based automobile
companies for General Motors and
Chrysler in 1988 started doing joint
normal joint research together then that
result of that was a creation of what's
now known as us car which has a several
several hundred million dollar joint
research sharing effort it has resulted
in as Jack Gibbons pointed out this
morning in collaborative work with the
federal government in an area where we
have parallel interests and that is in
the area of fuel economy energy
efficiency and manufacturing capability
that's in the partnership for a new
generation of vehicles we're still
evolving how to work together in that
area but that is one area where there is
a substantive joint agreement on how the
federal government and industry should
collaborate and it's a relatively large
scale collaboration our relationships
with industries with universities have
been evolving but not in in as easily
categorized way as our relationship with
our competitors or with with the federal
government it's a very delicate balance
that we have to strike we have a lot of
interest in what you might call fairly
applied kinds of research yet we know
that what we most want from universities
is in fact fairly unfettered exploration
into areas where the results are
unpredictable and and we also want very
very good students so we've been fairly
cautious about trying to work with
universities in a more directed manner
yet we do want to maintain ties and make
sure that the whole somehow is greater
than some of the parts one of the
approaches to this was a recent
down in New Orleans that Peter
Eisenberger who's here
championed and that was sponsored by the
Department of Energy and National
Science Foundation where people from the
National Labs and from from industry and
from universities got together to
discuss the general research priority
areas relevant to where the automotive
industry is going the automotive
industry by the way is a huge industry
and it affects about one job out of
seven in the United States something
else has happened though that I find
extremely remarkable and intriguing as
the industry has become more
science-based
because of of external exigencies we
find although although the it is not a
discipline based industry the importance
of researchers and of scientists has
become considerably expanded when I came
to Ford in 1986 except for the person
heading the research lab which was me
then there was one other individual in
the in the company who was a corporate
officer who had a doctorate
out of 40 corporate officers nowadays
out of the 40 corporate officers five of
them have doctorates out of 40 corporate
officers five of them have come out of
the research laboratory now this didn't
happen because all of a sudden the
corporation decided gee isn't science
wonderful it happened as a result of the
crises of the early 70s when when when
when the company was confronted with a
series of technique on Plex technical
demands that it didn't had a handle and
the the fastest most nimble people the
ones who are
able to grasp problems at the
fundamental level most rapidly indeed
had come from the research laboratory so
the payoff from having the cultural
equivalent of the Symphony Orchestra
within the corporation was something
which was extremely practical and that
was truly exceptional individuals the
net result of that today is that
although the research laboratory
represents only one percent of the
professional workforce at Ford it
represents one person out of every eight
of the corporate officers and they're
not distributed in the way that you
might expect the most obvious one I
suppose is myself who's in charge of
what's called technical affairs which is
research and Environment and safety and
other things worldwide
professional technical development for
all the scientists and engineers in the
company all 17,000 that's pretty obvious
kind of thing you'd expect for someone
coming out of a technical background and
also the vice-president for what's
called advanced vehicle technology where
all the vehicle programs in the company
arise happens to be a PhD physicist who
came out of the research lab but that's
a technical area there's some other
areas that are not so obvious the
vice-president for customer service is a
PhD chemist the vice president for new
business strategy is a PhD electrical
engineer who did not start his career in
the research lab but spent much of his
early career there but even farther
upstream in this business in the
automotive business at Ford which is
last year was 1.07 times 10 to the 11th
dollars
since it's a science-based business now
I have to put in scientific notation
that's big money
the head of all manufacturing for the
world
Bob transou the group vice-president for
manufacturing started off his career in
the research laboratory the head of all
of the automotive activity for the whole
company that whole 1.07 times 10 to the
11th dollars is I'm sorry to say this in
front of Allan Bromley a PhD nuclear
physicist pretty obvious isn't it should
be a PhD nuclear physicist who started
his career in the research laboratory
actually doing nonlinear optics and one
step higher up even there are two people
who are at higher up than the than the
head of all of a Ford automotive that's
the Chairman and vice chairman the
Chairman is not a nuclear physicist
however the vice chairman who was the
only other member of the company who was
on the board of directors is Lou Ross
who started off his career in the
research laboratory so the moral of the
story that I want to draw from that is
that one of the most important things
about science and this will lead up to
discussions later on this afternoon
isn't necessarily the the actual
technical content of the science but
it's the training and the education that
researchers research scientists receive
which enable them to hint to handle at a
very fun on a very fundamental basis
questions that are not understood and to
do it in a timely manner
and the the remarkable transformation
that has occurred as the automotive
industry has become more science-based
is nowhere more obvious than in the
science base
of its management and I think this has
implications probably for other
industries as they evolve and that it
also has implications for the importance
of very solid research experiences and
universities but it also suggests
opportunities for researchers and
students in particular in the basic
sciences at universities to start
thinking a little bit more broadly about
potential career opportunities thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Sean there is only
one person more pleased in any of us
that George Whitesides is here tonight
here this afternoon and that's Mark
Ryden
who as you all know was otherwise going
to have had to try impossible which is
to pretend to be George
professor Whitesides started his career
at Harvard and he's come back there
after some detours first to Caltech to
get his PhD in physical organic
chemistry he came back from there to the
faculty here at MIT and moved slightly
upriver in 1982 where he is now
Mallinckrodt professor at Harvard the
george has served on more serves on more
scientific advisory boards than most of
us as they used to say have hot
breakfasts the the he he goes from cars
to perfume and from magnetism to
biotechnology in his scientific contacts
with industry as far as the government
is concerned he sits on committees of
the National Research Council the
National Science Foundation the
Department of Defense and the Department
of Commerce with the greatest pleasure
George
I will see how this works
my various colleagues have come here I
think to tell you useful things I'm
coming here as you can tell as an
example of an area in which there's
excellent basic research to be done and
that's virology pathophysiology is a
place where I think there's some good
applied research to be done what I would
like to do is to give you my message as
far as I can upfront because I'm not
sure there's a later in this discussion
the message is that in fundamental
research there are some truly wonderful
opportunities and I think from the
academic point of view many of these
opportunities fall between the
conventional disciplines I think that in
these areas you can find splendid
applications that will create jobs and
goods and services given these facts
what's the problem why are we here and
the answer to that is I'm not quite sure
I think part of the problem is that
we've fallen into a semantic trap in
which we are spending quite a lot of
time worrying about the difference
between the fundamental and applied and
probably enough time going about the
business of trying to make the whole
system work better let me spend a few
minutes discussing some of the examples
which I would pick out as being good
examples of basic research areas in
which there's good basic research in
which they're also splendid applications
to go along with it
a way of analyzing research is to think
about extremes that is to think about
what the frontiers are in science at any
given point and what I'd like to do is
pick out an example or two of things
that are very small things that have new
properties things that are very large
something to do with the earth and the
environment and just point out how the
applied and pure kinds of distinctions
probably don't at least to me make a
great deal of sense in the area of small
for example there are now wonderful
wonderful tools which enable us to look
at distances that are in the order of
atoms or fractions of atoms this opens
from the point of view of fundamental
condensed matter physics the
opportunities to examine things like
quantum devices and quantum phenomena at
the scales of movements of electrons
even if these devices themselves never
make it into the real world they will
certainly enable new types of device
fabrication which in turn will make it
possible to make portable
telecommunication systems with very low
power it won't and offer the opportunity
to change our communication structure so
it's a kind of investment from a
national point of view and which one
almost can't lose as far as I can see in
terms of properties throughout material
science now one is finding new kinds of
materials being developed
one example is things which have the
general composition of carbon nitride
which may have the property that they're
harder than carbon no harder than
diamond the question of how you measure
something that's harder than diamond is
a little problematic but we'll figure
out how to do that what does one do with
that kind of technology then the answer
is you try to solve some of john McTigue
problems that is you apply it to
extremely tough materials with extremely
lightweight
there will be the sorts of materials
that are required to meet the the
performance and weight requirements for
the ultra low emission vehicles that the
automobile industry is now facing large
I mean one of my favorite experiments
now is one that's going on at MIT and
also at Caltech and that's the LIGO
experiment the gravity interferometer
experiment to measure gravity waves from
the point of view of fundamental science
I can't think of anything more exciting
than listening to the dying scream of a
neutron star as it falls into a black
hole a million years ago I mean I think
this is terrific stuff are better than
OJ at the same time this is producing
technology which I believe will
ultimately revolutionize metrics what
these people are doing in terms of their
measurements simply takes ones breath
away and it's going to be useful for
many things in terms of the earth we are
using in a breathtakingly clever way the
combination of ground-based sensors and
space-based sensors to watch the whole
planet shift and move the wonderful
combination of computation and sensing
at a very fundamental level the
application of course is to try to put
off happening in San Francisco or at
least warn San Francisco before it
becomes Kobe and this is no small stuff
if you live in San Francisco or Kobe and
then finally one of my favorite areas is
this issue of the environment and we all
are very interested in the environment I
fall a little bit in that category of
people who believe the sort of Gaia
hypothesis that there may be some
saintly self regulating quality to the
the environment and I thought for years
that the way that Earth that's thinking
of it as an organism might solve the
problem of having too many pestilential
human beings around was simply to turn
up the temperature and cook us
but the nice thing that's happened now
is we have a second hypothesis which is
this interesting issue of estrogen
equivalence which is that many many
chemicals may interact with the estrogen
receptor with the result that all of us
males are sterilized and there is a very
intriguing discussion going on now which
i think is good public policy of global
male sperm count what is the quality of
the global male sperm count a terrific
terrific discussion to have so what does
one do with this this whole story at the
moment it seems to me that I look at
this this combination of basic research
and Applied Research and I'm deeply
convinced that one can have we can have
our cake and eat it at the same time we
can do both basic research which is very
very good Applied Research so how do we
go about it I think for this audience I
would make just three suggestions and
they're in the order of three I suppose
criticisms there are three parties in
this story
there's the university there's
government and there's industry and each
of us has done some things very well and
has failed in some things from the
university's point of view I think what
we have done is to fail to explain what
it is we do in terms that connects the
fundamental to the the applied and we
have tried to fuss too much about this
semantic issue of the difference between
fundamental and applied we should just
forget it
is not that big a deal let's do good
research as Phil sharp said and make the
point that we'll try to be helpful where
we can and I think in practice we can
also do probably a much better job of
moving fundamental research to the point
where it's prototyped or prototype able
and can be understood by industry with
its present product focus so we can
in both of those areas from the point of
view of the government I would I think
make two suggestions I know trying to
make suggestions that the government is
not a very profitable thing to do but
I'll make them anyway I would criticize
the government for inconsistency in the
way it thinks about this problem the
university responds to changes very very
sluggishly
after all the lifetime of a student from
entering undergraduate school - leaving
graduate school as maybe 9 or 10 years
and if the problems on which we're
working are changing every two years we
have a hard time keeping up I think if
there were clear national consensus led
by the government as there were it was
for many years as to what the important
problems were we could help be very
helpful for years we understood who was
a high tech head of medical care high
tech health care and national security
and the university system was
extraordinarily good at working on
problems in those areas right now
there's a bit of switching around and
the switching is going on a little bit
more rapidly than we can keep up with so
for the government I would say try to be
consistent in the objectives and try not
to use the distinction between
fundamental and applied as an
ideological distinguishing feature
between the parties that doesn't help
any of us and then actually my most
serious criticism as say for the last
party which is industry because I think
there's something that industry can do
that would be very very helpful and
which will cost almost nothing um so
it's serious in the sense that I don't
understand why it isn't done what
industry can do is to encourage the
senior management the folks that John
McTigue was talking about just to
explain exactly what John said in public
in Washington I mean it's it's
remarkable to me that industry as it
moves away from basic research
internally will say that we rely more
and more
on basic research from somewhere else
but the senior management of prayers and
talks about tax policy or about GATT or
about things of that sort these are very
important topics I don't disagree with
that at all but the notion of having
industry be the bridge between the
university system and the users in
industry with the encouragement to
government to provide support in the
right fashion is something that I don't
think would take a great deal of effort
on the part of the senior management and
would have enormous impact so let me
summarize by finishing in finishing by
saying as I said at the beginning that
the opportunities are there the societal
needs are there the distinction between
basic and applied is purely artificial
it's very very hard to find most good
research being done in universities not
traceable to some useful interesting
thing that if that appears in in the
real world in some fashion and I think
that we would all benefit by working
hard to obliterate the distinction
between applied and and fundamental
rather than encouraging a debate as to
the relative merits of applied in
fundamental thank you
[Applause]
George thank you for that heroism and
we'll see if your voice runs out I'll
ask mark to come and sit at the table to
give the answer you would have given had
you been able questions comments what I
was suggesting is that the government
try to focus on problems which are
sufficiently important that they're
going to be around for a long while
those are the kinds of problems that we
can help with that's right that's like
trying to teach a hippopotamus to
tap-dance and he speaks with the
experience
[Laughter]
yes I guess we've talked about the when
does the basic research or research as I
agree would join me to talk about it
seems to me the reason we're here is
because the society has a finite amount
of resources and it doesn't do good
enough talk about the good things one
can do the one has to talk about how we
can do them more effectively in the past
because that's what all sectors of the
society are being asked to do so I'd be
interested in some speakers thoughts on
how we could accomplish our good tasks
more effectively well part of it I think
was the issue I was trying to get at
earlier and that is this country wastes
an enormous amount of resource on
litigiousness it does that in the
obvious area of civil trials etc but it
also does it in the area that we're
talking about here the adversarial
relationship that exists between the
various elements of our society in in
the technical arena really hurts us we
regulation environmental regulation for
example regulations are arrived at by in
our adversarial proceeding believe it or
not so-called reg negs you know people
get in the room and argue with each
other and finally somebody gets tired
they're not done on a science base or a
risk assessment base or an economic
assessment base they're done on the
basis of how two lawyers would argue a
case what has happened in Superfund for
example is is a classic example of
what's going wrong I just noticed Nick
Sami os-- shaking his head actually
shaking his head yes the OI sakes is
that no to make
the problem of how we run our National
Labs is a disgrace absolute disgrace
wasting an enormous amount of resource
that could be aimed at a technical
purpose instead of these silly responds
to my request or my demand for this
report by october 15th if we could find
a way to agree that we're all in this
boat together at some level there is an
enormous resource that we can free up
that could be applied toward the tasks
that to hand certainly Georgia's three
points for each of them as it were
educational in some sense that people
that neither government industry nor I
could email worth clarifying their
objectives or and certainly not
transmitting them is that fair George
that's a point and then the other point
I would precisely support what John just
said if we in fact agree that we are all
in it together then I think the
resources there the manpower is there
the question is how does one most
effectively find out that we are all in
it together and if I had probably a
single suggestion to make it would be to
work much harder to find ways of moving
people back and forth between the
sector's because I don't know how you
really find out what's going on
somewhere else other than to go there
and in in among these three sectors the
University and government and industry
one might as well be talking in many
cases about China Nigeria and Madison
Avenue it's just the cultures are very
very far apart
look it seems to me we talk about
communications public relations working
better together but not really digging
in deeper and asking serious questions
which I believe that just be as done
when they look at themselves of how we
can do this research Enterprise better
really make changes that may have some
some bite into them some change I get a
feeling some Halloween the question
we're giving is a plutocrat if we were
all friends with each other
that will solve all the problems that
exist and I just don't really believe
that that's the case I think there are
really resource questions lots more to
be done ways of making choices ways of
doing things in the educational system
better than we have done in the past
that require real change not just
relabeling and not just better
advertisement or communication I part of
that is true and one of the things I was
trying to discuss earlier was the
necessity for actually working together
and that you can get to first I know
certainly when Ford General Motors and
Chrysler worked together it's not
because we love each other we will kill
for one point of market share
probably that has happened in the past
[Laughter]
yet we do find it in our each and our
self-interest to work together in a
circumscribed set of circumstances which
are not transparent and which are not
obvious to the customer that don't are
not customer differentiates where it
gives us if the capability of doing
things that we couldn't otherwise do
with our limited resources we're doing
the same thing with the government the
government's doing without doing it with
us not because they love us either so
there are efficiencies that can be
gained by trying to find ways to work
together but I truly believe that there
are much bigger efficiencies and the
bigger efficiencies are in these
terribly dissipative adversarial
processes that are
autoimmune response of our society
producing good I think probably we
better move on without wishing to move
on while we're still a kind kinder and
gentler body I hope that our questioner
can sharpen up our two recipients during
the break but thank you both
we now have the maybe appropriately the
final I'm in the final section on
information on and on information
transmission after all the first speaker
is William Brinkman we leave the
chemists now he did a PhD at the
University of Missouri in physics and
joined Bell Labs almost immediately in
1966 having done and this is the sort of
quasi academic activity a postdoctoral
year in Oxford I call that quasi
academic the in nineteen by 1981 he was
director of the physical research lab at
Bell and he then took what one might
call a quasi-governmental stint by three
years at Sandia before returning to Bell
in 1987 where he is now Physical
Sciences Research vice-president he's
responsible for all the physical
sciences opto electronic electronic
devices optical fibers and almost
everything else dr. Brinkman where is he
there is
well I have to tell you that I got the
program and discovered I was supposed to
talk about the information to
communication Sciences hi I'm physicists
I read the physical sciences part of
laboratories and Sciences but I decided
that I was okay that that what I would
do today was talk about AT&T after all
it is your communications company your
communication company is surely your
true voice how much they regret the
breakup of AT&T the only people I know
who don't regret Baker the breakup of
AT&T or the people who own stock an att
just before divestiture because if you
actually add up today the value of the
stock that you would have had look what
it would be today it's roughly three
times what it was ten years it's very
well the stock ATT before it was broken
up was about a sixty billion dollar
company today AT&T itself is a 77
billion dollar company and it's seven
operating companies or roughly ten each
so it went from a sixty billion dollar
company to a hundred and forty billion
if you add them all together so this is
this I think we should think of this is
the new telecommunications Ihram it is
totally different than what it was
before the people that done that the
things that are happening are dramatic
if I showed you a view graph of what we
thought of as being the AT&T network in
1984 it would be a network with with
telephones hanging off of it today our
network is it is it is the last thing we
would show you is a picture of a
telephone hanging off of the end of our
network
it would have computers would have video
terminals that have cellular phones it's
cetera like that so the industry is
changing enormous lis cellular business
is growing at about 30 percent per year
Internet as I'm sure will hear in the
next talk is growing at 40 percent per
year the long distance network our long
distance network overseas network will
probably change from a voice dominated
network to a data dump data video etc
dominated Network this year if it isn't
already our overseas communication
certainties already dominated by fax and
so on so what has happened is this thing
that for a hundred and ten years was a
voice dominated telephone network is
turned into a totally different business
and so rapidly growing that we today
think that if we want to maintain our
market share in the next 10 years our
company has to grow from 70 billion to
200 billion because we think that but
then Communications is going to grow at
that kind of rate so needless to say
there's enormous change occurring in
telecommunications is probably one of
the most rapidly changing businesses
today it's it's exciting why what have
brought this about why now well the
answer is that everyone all of the
scientists and technologists in this
room were largely responsible for why
now you know it's it's very interesting
to go and look look and try to
understand that in some detail after all
the transistor was invented in 1948 but
that is really the story the story is
that the transistor was invented in 1948
the FE T was actually patented in 1954
but the FE T first Fe T was made in 1960
that Fe T was such a lousy device nobody
used it until the early 70s when places
that while I was made a day at AT&T
places like IBM cleaned up the FE T
until it was a good and sufficiently
good good
I took the sodium out of it etc etc
until it was a sufficiently good device
so that we had we could use we could
start doing CMOS in the late 70s the
late 70s started CMOS and that's what
started to generate the integrated
circuit business in a big way and so
that throughout the 80s the integrated
circuit business went from a killer sort
of a kilobit storage to mega bits we
know today and will go on to Giga bits
in the next century but what that going
from that last ten years meant is we've
got we've undergone enormous change as
you everyone knows about the computer
industry that that we now have computers
that are that are as powerful as these
things the big mainframes of the 60s and
70s sitting at home in our desktops but
not only we got that we have we now have
cellular phones that you stick in your
shirt pocket that will be that are
equivalent to pen that are put on PCMCIA
cards which slip into your computer
those sell your phones into late 70s
we're actually a case size box in the
trunk of your car with wires running up
to a phone in front of your car that's
the size they were only 12 years ago so
the integrated circuit business what
while it sounds like it was here a long
time ago actually arrived about 1980 and
that's what we really have to recognize
the second thing that arrived almost
simultaneously with that is it new means
of communications and that is called
that is a quartz optical fiber optical
fiber was worked on throughout the 70s
but the first system was actually
introduced in 1982 we are only thirteen
years later in that system the system is
an interesting system is 45 megabits on
a single fiber first 45 megabits per
second on a single fiber 1982 we had
vice-presidents at AT&T saying gee we
don't need 45 megabit transmission
you know we will never use fiber we've
always used coaxial cable we don't need
45 megabits today we are installing at
the end of this year across the Atlantic
like five fibre cable that will have
five gigabits per second on each fiber
we do experiments in the lab today at a
third of a terabit per second so fiber
has dramatically changed what you can do
in communications yet to think about a
third of a terabit per second W let's
see five gigabits is 250,000 phone call
voice conversations some crazy number
like that it is it has reduced the cost
of a transatlantic cable on a per voice
basis to $400 $400 that's less money
than it cost to put a drop from a
telephone pole into your house right but
you could get a voice channel across the
Atlantic for 400 bucks so what has
happened is there's just a dramatic
increase in what you can do in
communications brought on by the
technology has brought about what we
find ourselves today is in the industry
in which this stuff has all become a
beacon become come upon us and now we're
not sure how to use how the world will
communicate in the neck in 20 years from
now is clearly going to be entirely
different than it is today and you're
starting to see this coming very rapidly
now with cd-roms you're on your
computers we just introduced a telephone
a set-top box that you can plug your
telephone into so that in fact you can
dial up and put things right onto your
television without a terminal and
without a PC there is enormous change in
fact I maintained there is a a major
battle going to occur in the next ten
years to think
out what what the home will look like
from an electronic point of view okay
now there's another major thing that we
have to resolve and that is that all of
this stuff has to communicate with each
other itself with other pieces of this
network that we're going to create and
there's an enormous challenge in trying
to understand how to see to it that
everything communicates and what we're
going to go through is a period of time
in which that is all in a very confused
state of affairs because we have lived
for 110 years with a very
straightforward way of communicating and
that is when you dial up your telephone
with your telephone you get a connection
now it may be ace a time slot on on some
very high bitrate stream but you get
that time slot every time you reserved
okay that time slot therefore is like a
wire is from all practical purposes
between the two locations that is not
what you're going to get in the future
and the reason you can't we can't give
you that in the future is that sometimes
you're going to want boys sometimes
you're gonna want video and sometimes
you're gonna want to hit us with an
enormous amount of data and in one big
shot and and so if we want to do all
those things it isn't going to be
possible to just decide to give you time
slots because how are we gonna decide
what time floods to give you and how
much to give you we can't give you video
rate time slots all the time when you're
only doing voice so the whole new
algorithms are being establishes
protocols etc to try to understand this
thing's these things are enormous
challenges to to us as a research and
development arm of AT&T to understand
these things and to work these things
out so it when I look at our industry
today we we are confronted with
something that's very very different
than its
been in the history of AT&T and and that
clearly checks us in a very different
fashion and and if you think that this
can that's some hard research
organizations gonna be immune to this
kind of dynamic forget that's that's not
in the cards at all today and in
particular we have to get back out and
we have to be in front of this after all
this is a revolution we created
it's an exciting one of the most
exciting thing that's happened in a long
time and so we are we have been moving
very rapidly and into creating a much
larger organization that addresses the
kinds of issues I've discussed these are
important fundamental issues to
communication theory and it's going to
change the dynamic of the world
therefore what's happened in an AT&T in
the research is we've had to
de-emphasize to a large extent a lot of
the physical sciences so that we can
attack these kinds of system problems
now I asked you I just described
industry to you it's very hard to figure
out what else you would do in that
circumstance right and so so you you've
got we we are in a mode in which which
we must address these issues we must
understand as much as we can about what
what people will want in future
telecommunications that is a critical
issue now personally I think don't want
everything what I what I believe we're
gonna find is that the world is has an
enormous diversity of people and how
people use communications will vary in
just about as enormous ly as a diversity
of people and so there will be no answer
to who to who to what exact set of tools
we will use in communications some
people will want wireless some people
want videos that's it that's it there's
gonna be a lot of different things and
so we have have to do to to address
these kinds of issues now that doesn't
mean that the same time that there are
two enormous issues on the physical
sciences
side of the ledger for example right now
in the industry essentially what is
going on is there is a battle for the
access to the home right now if you look
at it the regional operating companies
and the CATV companies have the
communication access to your house all
right and the question becomes how is
that going to evolve well you know for
sure that in the near distant future
wireless access will be available at
your house you won't have to just use a
cellular phone at all outside so your
phones will come down in price there
would be more bandwidth given out the
FCC is doing it today and you will be
able to just simply use Wireless in your
home now whether that'll come so that's
one aspect the other aspect is who is
going to supply video how many well this
two telephone companies well just the
CATV company supplying a video when you
get video from both the CATV and your
local operating company will local
operating company essentially be a a
conduit which allows other people to
rent the line to your house so there's a
brewing and Congress is it and in this
country is an enormous battle over this
access to your house it's a very
important battle and how that goes is
gonna be a lot determined by technology
whether we we could make continued to
drive the price of Wireless down can't
wait whether we can figure out how to
make micro cells instead of the cellular
cells the base station cells you have
today which are typically five miles
apart whether you can make much closer
blorp our directional cetera so that you
can you can you can increase the
bandwidth of wireless after all if you
really if you really make the sale small
and if you could put video over wow it's
just a ways you could put it over over
wired and so so exactly how the
technology all these technologies evolve
is going to redefine the communications
industry in the United States
in the next 20 years a very exciting
time I think when I think about basic
research and ask myself what what how
does it interact with this industry I
think the first thing you have to
understand is is that paradigm that I
just described enormous change we have
to go with the people that are a premier
Premier people today or people who know
about communications protocols software
those are the kinds of people that are
at a premium are being eaten alive today
in addition the wireless business that
is growing so rapidly it has left us in
a very peculiar place in this country we
cannot find enough RF engineers isn't
that strange you would never think you
would run short of RF engineers but
today I can tell you if you're an RF
engineer you can get a job all over our
industry because there are there just we
the university system has essentially
decided 20 years ago in fact as we and
many other companies decided 20 years
ago wireless wasn't RF was not a very
important subject anymore and so most
people got out and they left it behind
and it's no longer longer people are
trained in design and so we're very much
missing these people and we find
everybody paying a high premium for that
right now but in in our world today
because of this diamond of change when
we look at the physical sciences we have
to make take much harder looks than
we've ever had before and we have to
find we have to rationalize our behave
our set of activities in some kind of
priorities fashion we cannot sit back
and say gee let's support them all and
we can't and let the flowers bloom and
then we'll go pick that is not the mode
we're in we don't have the money or
resources to do that
therefore in in physical sciences we've
had to look at these things very
carefully and it is it is interesting
that the community as a whole my opinion
has not stepped up to to to some
rationalization of priorities or the
basic research side that that that helps
you walk through this this kind of
change and I mean that sincerely if if I
leave it if we leave it to corporate
America corporate America will make that
judgment strictly on the basis of
applications and I believe the issue is
deeper than that we talked about it here
today but the fact of the matter it is
it is being made on that basis today if
there is a better basis we have not
found it yet and I personally believe
that there is I believe that I believe
that we are glossing over the problem
when we say all these things keep
everything going and we don't know where
the big great breakthroughs are going to
come so we have to do that just I
believe that we have to come up with a
better rationalization of that than that
and I think the way to do that is you do
have to look historically at fields and
asked where they are in their maturity
curve I'm a physicist I don't care what
anyone says condensed matter physics
today is a mature field it is not having
the impact it did in the 1940s 50s and
60s in 1940s for God's sakes concept of
a hole in a semiconductor which was a
basic piece of fire science led to the
beginning of this whole revolution I
don't know what concept and that's
matter physics today that could that
anyone would like to argue would lead to
that kind of a revolution and and so we
can rationalize these things it is not
impossible to decide what feels armature
and which feels aren't and we just have
to face up to that issue and I think we
have intended I think you were getting
nervous in your chair so I better sit
down thank you very much
I was only getting nervous about being
attacked by condensed matter physicists
our last speaker is dr. Anita Jones who
in case you hadn't read quite cleverly
enough her a being right was from rice
in math she then took a little detour
and did an MA the masters at University
of Texas is Austin in literature so we
are going to have a properly cultivated
last talk followed that while a PhD at
the Carnegie Mellon in computer science
dr. Jones has been chair of computer
science the University of Virginia and
then entered government service on the
defense Science Board and the Air Force
scientific advisory board since 1993
she's been director of defense research
in engineering that is responsible for
all science and engineering at the
Department of Defense and including all
kinds of excitements like ARPA with
pleasure
dr. Jones thank you I'm the hybrid that
represents the government on this on
this panel and I thought I could best
play the part by making a handful of
observations of how why and what's
changing about the way government funds
information science so I'm going to
start with the fundamentals there are a
number of reasons places where it's
appropriate in the United States for
government to fund science and general
information science in particular this
is a time of change certainly speaking
for the Defense Department as you are
often told our threat of imminent
large-scale warfare is tremendously
diminished from my point of view looking
over the Science and Technology program
I will tell you that the competition
just heated up
we had leisurely procurement cycles that
happen to be precisely the same length
on the average of 15 point 5 years of
that of the former Soviet Union but the
next kind of battle albeit is smaller
our forces will be fighting against any
kind of arms that you can find in the
international arms market and that could
be based on technology developed in in
any advanced countries in the in the
world and so on item 2 our mission
remains and the competition is heavier
let me point out that in this this
debate about how and what government
should fund in particularly in the
Universities particularly in fundamental
science whether an industry or the
universities a objective and obligation
that the government has had over the
last several decades is paying a
substantial portion of the graduate
education in a number of fields and I
can tell you in DoD we put a substantial
amount of resources into funding
students graduate students whereas the
the National Science Foundation funds
about twelve thousand students a year
DoD funds eight thousand so about 75
percent of that amount and as questions
are asked by the military inside the DoD
and on the hill
what should Defense Fund there's a real
issue I think that will be come to the
fore again this year about what defense
should do in terms of funding students I
believe it's important for the
government agencies across the board to
nurture the future scientists and
engineers and picking up a point that
George Whiteside made earlier I think
industry needs to make a statement in
this discussion of what kind of
investment the government should make
with their tax money and nurturing the
infrastructure of the of the country let
me turn to funding of information
science and let me start with something
that Jack alluded to he and the Clinton
administration created the National
Science and Technology Council it's got
nine subcommittees I chair the Committee
on information and communications it's
one of nine and I want to tell you a few
of the things that's happening under
that Aegis budget numbers are hard to
pin down they're very slippery Devils
we took a cross-cut voluntarily not all
the numbers approved looking at R&D in
information sciences and this is this is
the kind of results we got you see
across the horizontal axis some areas of
investment the units are millions of
dollars or hundreds of millions of
dollars excuse me and and the two codes
the upper portion of the bars are those
things that are included under the major
initiative that's under the NSTC
Committee on information and
communications and that's the high
performance computing and communications
initiative this roughly adds up to two
billion dollars again it's at the back
of the envelope accuracy no more and
roughly half of it is considered part of
the high performance it's an investment
in the high performance end of these
areas this is a major a flagship
initiative for the Clinton
administration the major components
today of this initiative are listed on
this particular slide one of the basic
premises are that the government should
invest in the very high end problems the
very high end technologies the
government invest in the long term the
government oughta saw
the problems we're gonna see a couple of
generations out because that solving
some of those problems at at the
research level in the laboratories will
set the scene for new products for
industry to derive it at later dates
Frank Rhodes said this is a particular
area and he called out the high
performance computer and communications
initiative and said it's it's in need
it needs a synthesis that the National
Science and Technology Council provides
and I'd like to say that it's getting
that this is this is a premier example
of the virtual agency concept there are
a number of agencies the the large
dollar investors in this initiative are
DOD through ARPA energy NASA and NSF
this is not new money this is money that
those agencies were probably would have
put in computing and communications the
initiative is the forum though for the
agencies to come together the program is
bottom-up planned the money remains in
the agencies and those agencies put
their mission first I happen to believe
that's appropriate but in fact
information technology and the long term
research problems are so ubiquitous
totally applicable that many of the
agencies see the same kind of problems
need to be solved to achieve their
mission and so you see a lot of joint
investment for example under this
initiative we are fielding the so-called
handful of gigabit test beds the more
recent program under this initiative is
joint between ARPA NASA and the National
Science Foundation in digital library in
digital libraries which is an
interesting interesting arena and from
my experience with this virtual agency
Oshin which I was Jack quite skeptical
of when I first joined the government a
couple of years ago really is working it
does eliminate much of what is
unnecessary duplication there's a lot of
partnering as exampled by the the
gigabit test beds which are
predominantly funded through ARPA and
the National Science Foundation and the
digital libraries this is a particular
initiative and a second point I want to
make is that it's evolving rapidly and
the interagency process is helping that
when this initiative started in the
early 90s and it was difficult to get
the agencies around the table in a
cooperative way and and quite a heroic
thing I think focus was on the Grand
Challenges of science real-time weather
modeling fundamental physical reactions
computational fluid dynamics the focus
was on teraflop computing and on gigabit
networks in fact within a couple of
years later the initiative evolved
because I think the research problems
are changing as rapidly as the
information industry's product cycles
and so new new things come to the fore
and the the the major event I think in
the evolution of this particular
initiative was to add a new portion of
the high performance computing and
communications initiative and that was
the the society based national
challenges healthcare applications
energy app Climate global climate
applications and in fact right now I can
I can tell you from my vantage point
that this is initiative that is changing
the next step is to rethink the set of
problems and the
fundamental basis for the initiative we
have done a a strategic planning
exercise under the NSTC aegis and have
picked these six focus areas as being
important and we are going to reevaluate
make a slight change to the strategic
focus of the initiative it has gone from
having a very Hardware focus to a much
heavier software and application focus I
think in in this round of evolution you
will see some of the more holistic
problems address one of the comments
John Hopcroft from Cornell made over the
over lunch was high performance
computing initiative focused on networks
that's just getting bits from here to
there the real issue is communications
whether it's as dr. Brinkman said the
the RF communications the scale of
network speeds that one has to cope with
all the way from very slow speed which
is something that we see partly by
choice to have a low profile in DoD
applications battlefield applications up
to very high speed and these things have
to coexist and be communication systems
we do have a fairly chaotic way of
having the government talk to the nation
talk to the universities more
particularly talk to industry it's
usually through a set of forums a set of
advisory groups a set of workshops and
so on one next action that will happen
in this context and this I'm only
looking at a narrow context and a larger
Science and Technology program is to
have some workshops in dialogue with
industry the industry associations about
what should be the strategic voci
in the information science area and so
the second point that I wanted to make
is that this virtual agency notion has
become real under this under this
administration and I think it's
returning value and I've tried to show
you one example and some of the changes
that are happening in that example next
observation rate break is I want to talk
about one particular relatively small
program that I think is very exciting
that is funded in defense because I want
to tell you about how we make that
investment and how that is quite
different than typically what you'd find
a university doing or what industry
doing the area of Technology Development
is micro electrical mechanical systems
for those of you who haven't met these
little beasties
it's very exciting and then instead of
just having a a chip that kind of lays
there and and computes on information
you give it a sensor so it can sense the
environment and give it an actuator so
it can do something about the sensed
information that it's computed on and
chewed on and take an action that is
felt in that environment and there are
lots of applications in fluid sensing
accelerometers optical devices sound and
even liquid movement kind of
applications one of the and again I said
this was going to be a small example one
of the programs that we've put together
is a successor to Moses the
metal-oxide-semiconductor
service that we had for semiconductors
is called multi-user MEMS projects it's
through the micro electronics Center in
North Carolina and I think this is a
good example of how the government how
DoD in particular ought to invest in a
particular technology this is a
fabrication facility if you have a
design of a a combination mechanical and
an electrical
Mike MEMS
device send us electronically of course
that design plus a token amount of money
and some number of weeks later you get
half a dozen die having fabricated your
design and so this is a service the
users are depicted here in color federal
use is the top slivers in blue
University use is the black is in black
and is slightly dominant industrial use
is in red and about half of that
industrial use is small business and so
what this service permits is for both
University projects to operate in
start-up mode and get some experience
with this technology and for small
business also to have an entree to
fabrication lines that they could not
otherwise afford or get contractual
access to is the kind of thing that
government ought to do this is long term
there are some short term applications
that are coming to the fore the one of
the premier applications that exists
today is your your airbag trigger device
that's a MEMS MEMS device I think it's
important that the government and this
is my observation for for this segment
is the government ought to look for
enabling ways of making investment and I
proffer this as a reasonable example of
that or turn now to investment in
information science based on the NSF
science indicators report this is what
the government is investing in excuse me
both basic and applied will use those
terms again research and information
science that report breaks it out into
math and computer science and electrical
engineering this is part of a consistent
sustain long term many decades
investment by the government in
information sciences
the government has been remarkably
consistent I want to put my DoD hat on
the the smaller bars are the DoD
component of that investment the bars in
green are the total government
investment DoD is roughly I think 16
percent of the the total set of research
dollars that are being considered here
as I said on the very first slide
agencies invest in their mission two of
the most important areas are a most
important set of technologies for
defense certainly during my my tenure in
in overseeing the science and technology
program is information sciences and so
we are inordinate percentage of that
investment there are chilly winds
blowing particularly on the hill in
terms of asking questions of exactly
what or even whether DoD should be
investing in university research and
that gives me great concern
I've already highlighted the student
investment we make in fact I think to a
first approximation well let me say
differently DoD has funded the majority
of microelectronics advanced graduate
students who have been funded by the
government because we have a substantial
portion of not just these two
investments but later stage electronics
investments as well it's absolutely
crucial as every one of you know to have
a sustained investment in a research
area over years it doesn't matter
whether it's coming from from DoD or
coming from do-e or coming from from NIH
one needs to sustain it to sustain the
infrastructure in the country
and so let me also again go back and
take further the comment that the George
Whiteside made I think the important
thing that industry can do is to say to
the nation at large what it feels or the
degree to which it feels it's important
for the government to sustain these
long-term investments the government and
long-term investment in information
science is as best I can figure it
several times larger than the long-term
investment not the short-term but the
long-term investment that industry is
able to make because typically it must
have something like a a several year
horizons let me close with this slide
this is a derivative slide from from a
really interesting piece of analysis
that isn't a report that's just coming
out of the Academy chaired by ivan
sutherland fred brooks read the
horizontal axis is time we're talking
information science now and ten
technology really because you're gonna
see market on here the vertical axis is
just if you give me a cut me a little
slack breakthrough technology areas
within information technology the red is
when the government invested not how
much but when the government invested
the blue is when there was a serious
industry investment and the black is
when you had more than a billion dollars
of business based on that aspect of
information technology and you see it
goes all over the map in some cases
government made the early investment
followed by industry if you look at the
risk that's the reduced instruction set
computers it's a concept of make
instruction set simple rather than
complex in fact IBM made the early
investment with the IBM 801
I've got some of the notes on the side
flipped so ignore that but apparently
decided that was not a good perturbation
in their market and so they did not
follow it government then invested in
risk and you will see on front page of I
think yesterday's Wall Street Journal
Intel making announcement that it's its
next-generation processor would be risk
based this partnership between the
government and industry but by the way
university because the bulk of the are
the majority of the long-term research
funded by government at least for
defense is out in the universities is
absolutely crucial in information
sciences and I think this shows you some
of the richness of that fabric it is
important I believe to sustain this
investment and I believe it's absolutely
crucial that the nation understand this
notion of long term government
investment and I think it's likewise
absolutely crucial that the the one
party who is most objective and that
being industry as opposed to the
self-serving government people like me
or the self-serving University people
who get the bulk of the government money
in a long term research stand up and
talk about what's important and maybe
what's dumb about the way we're making
this investment but I think it's crucial
in the country that we that we continue
it thank you
I need first to ask the deans permission
where is he
for whether we may have a couple of
questions we are now 18 minutes we
started 15 behind schedule and we're now
18 not bad but are we say all right we
are please dr. Brinkman where are you
come questions we are we have been given
a dispensation by it by a decay no
dispensation yes Phil sorry I think that
if you're not careful with your charge
to the audience's dictate the areas
basic research i scantiness afford a
much broader basic research basis
I don't think because times are hard
that now's the time to retrench and
start making selections we all have to
make selections every day make a
selection once a week the funding of
science and if you look certainly clear
that biological sciences that have
become very large compared to physical
science in the last 10 or 15 years it's
also clear that Computer Sciences is
grown
let's see 30,000 employees in R&D so
billion dollars our research
organization it's like any other central
research organization large corporation
has had a lot of pressure on a to
survive to help the corporation you know
from 1984 tonight today I would say
eighties a new company it's broken up
into business units many business units
went through enormous change to survive
basically so those those changes have
caused a lot of people screaming at our
doors and now not next week so we've had
very strong but underneath that question
was presumably a desired
no the comparative or proportionate
investment into Rd of say biotechnology
versus communications was that
underlying your question let me try that
from the I've tried to get the same
answer generally there are several
looked at several sources to make
estimates of how large is is the
information technology interest industry
and the best I can figure out is it's
five to six hundred billion dollars a
year so let's say this is a very
aggressive fast moving industry let's
say they put ten percent in Rd okay so
that's 60 billion per year how much of
that is long term very small piece
should I pick 10 or 20% john of that
well 5 times 60 is 5% of 60 billion is 3
billion a year
it's always exactly the same size but
very different you have to remember a
couple things
AT&T acquired NCR 9 million dollar
company it acquired
McCaw another 12 billion dollar company
so if you look at the core of AT&T the
total R&D has gone down but yeah but
with the acquisitions it's kept almost
constant more concerns the primary
concern maybe 40 in which case let me
thank all the six contributors very much
indeed for this are clean